today we have a chef teaching us about
science let's see how he does
put it back parabens are safe at low
doses he's citing the ewg who don't know
what dose is last year the EU said there
wasn't enough info to say purple paraben
distracts hormones and they did
specifically say it doesn't disrupt
estrogen
any product here fragrance shaving cream
with fragrance people like fragrance it
smells nice
fragrance that's the key word if you see
that put it back because that's the
Cosmetics version of natural flavors
ifra has rules that everyone follows if
they listed everything in the fragrance
you still wouldn't know the doses and
you can't generalize 3 000 different
chemicals
issues and they find these fragrances
this mostly gesture scientists are
really good at measuring things
color in the body wash while it's with
blue one and red 33 artificial coloring
but those are almost always derived from
tar or petroleum petrochemicals aren't
too dangerous like the plastic he's
touching